Democrat parents get this issue as well
as Republican parents this is an issue
that actually unites parents across the
board in South Carolina they were
stunned by the developments across the
country as it relates to your ability to
have a gender identity group and to have
teachers feeling like they're forced to
provide instruction that is just
antithetical to what's in the best
interest of a child to exclude the
parent from any conversation around
those very important topics and so this
legislation would pull money away from
schools who refuse to comply with with
the law by the way of the land already
is
miners don't make decisions in a vacuum
it requires a parental supervision to
make those decisions I have to reinforce
that by pulling the money away so that
we can make them pay attention to what
the law of the land already is
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
senator from South Carolina as well as
the author of the new book America a
Redemption story choosing hope creating
Unity Senator Tim Scott finally welcome
to the Reuben report well thank you Dave
it's good it's good to be with you thank
you very much for having me I look
forward to our conversation we have lots
to talk about but the good news is I'm
excited to finally be on the show
well it goes both ways we've been trying
to get you on for quite some time the
schedules haven't quite matched up but
here we are so let's let's dive right
into it sir because I want to talk about
the book but I obviously want to talk
about current events and election and
and all of that stuff and uh you know
some of the some of the things you're
doing right now but first the the
general point of the book is positivity
it is decency it is something that
seemingly everyone talks about but
nobody does particularly well I include
myself in that sometimes I try to do it
I often fail can you talk a little bit
about how your life LED you to writing
something based in that idea you know
Dave the America Redemption story is a
book that I see as a positive view of
the world as it is not as I hope that it
will be and the truth is that what I
learned through life is that the pain
that I've gone through has helped to
clarify my purpose that my obstacles
have become the opportunities and
frankly the mess I made of my life has
become my message so the truth is that
yes it's a positive book but it's not
one of those Pie in the Sky hoping that
something will be different than it is
it's the reality of what is there is a
way for us to bring forth a positive
message in the midst of the chaos and
frankly I'm sure we'll talk about
inflation and some of the other
challenges that we see today as the kid
who grew up during the Carter years I
thank God Almighty for Ronald Reagan and
so the truth is that I learned why I
love President Ronald Reagan because of
the misery of high and inflation even
higher interest rates and scarcity not a
mentality but at the gas pump so the
truth is that when I think about the
hardest times I've seen in my life
somehow someway a silver lining appeared
and that book talks about that silver
lining in a race it talks about it with
the former president it talks about it
in winning and losing elections it talks
about it through this economic challenge
that we're going through right now so I
find the silver lining when it's there
when it's not there I just tell the
blunt truth that it's not there so so it
can be tough to find the silver lining
with so many of the things going on
right now between inflation and supply
chain and the war not war in Ukraine and
a whole bunch of other stuff but do you
think do you really view Us in that
Jimmy Carter moment right now which
maybe could cause you know sort of a red
pilling of Americans the average
American that didn't realize that maybe
big government doesn't work and printed
money doesn't work and the rest of it
well David you're a you're right the big
government has not worked and we have a
history to prove that it doesn't work uh
inflation is led by this one concept
that you talked about
spending money you don't have buying
things you don't need how do we prove
that well 1.9 trillion dollars on a
coveted relief package with one percent
for coveted vaccines that led to pouring
literal gasoline not literal figurative
gasoline on the fire right give them
give them some time when they're getting
rid of reserves yeah and then you go 1.2
trillion dollars after that in an
infrastructure bill that had 10 percent
for roads and bridges over the next five
years you you follow that up with a
739 billion dollar
Plan called reduction inflation
reduction act and it's really the
inflation acceleration act and not only
does it accelerate inflation but it
actually adds more fuel to the fire by
having the IRS comb through your file so
to speak targeting people under 200 000
a year so the truth is this is like the
Jimmy Carter years in that
gas is high inflation is high and
interest is creeping up and that's a
problem that causes the recession when
combined with the overspending in
Washington
so anytime I have a republican on
Congressman Senator doesn't matter I
basically ask one question always which
is do you think they are doing this
intentionally do you believe that they
think this stuff works or is this you
know what people are calling sort of
like a calculated implosion Dave that's
a great question I can't say that the
the rank and file Democrats have a
strategy
to have the economy implode because of
the pressure of inflation the pressure
of interest rates what I can tell you is
that the strategy to Slow Roll interest
rate increases had a lot to do from my
perspective of people being up for
reappointment it had something to do
with trying to satisfy the the whims and
the wishes of the Biden Administration
and that combination rather intentional
or not led to an acceleration of
inflation in a way that we haven't seen
since the Carter years so I don't
imagine that they have a grand design to
completely destroy the American economy
I do think they have a grand design to
change the very DNA of the American
people when you look at what's happening
it's undeniable that what is clearly
happening is a centralization in
decision making and in spending when you
take the power and the money and you put
them in the same place that is by Design
and that is bad for everybody outside
the Beltway
so when you talk to or or if you talk to
say a Democrat Governor maybe uh I just
fled California now I live in the Free
State of Florida if you were to talk to
Gavin Newsom or if you have talked to
him or just one of the Democrats Hotel
up in New York Whitmer whoever it might
be yeah I mean do they think what
they're doing is good I mean putting
aside whether it works or not I mean
just the intention I I'm still I'm still
unclear on this I just can't figure it
out well Dave I I have to hope that
their intentions are good I don't know
the mind of the person so I try my best
not to decide whether their intentions
are good or not but what I can tell you
is that if you're living in California
or Illinois let me say this way Dave in
the words of the CEO of McDonald's
headquartered in Illinois they are very
concerned not just with the taxes but
with the violence they literally say
people are overdosing in our restaurants
that violent crime is happening in our
restaurants if this is the Chicago and
the Illinois that is in our future
we're concerned that we can't stay
that should have reverberated throughout
all of the country and specifically in
Illinois governor pritzker should have
said OMG McDonald's is now speaking out
about the crime McDonald's is speaking
out about overdoses in their restaurant
whatever I am doing in this state I
should apologize and quit or if I'm not
going to do those two things apologize
and do a 180 degree turn in the opposite
direction here's what we know works we
know that rule of law works we know that
an objective standard for the rule of
law being applied equally works we know
that no bail doesn't work we know that
defunding the police doesn't work we
know that creating tribalism doesn't
work so if we know these things don't
work why does Gavin Newsom not know that
why does Governor pritzker not know that
I don't have an answer for what's going
through their cranial cavity I can tell
you it's time to stop yes and that's why
I ask you sort of the same question in
two ways because when you see 350 000
people flee California which is what
happened last year you'd think Gavin
might go I don't know maybe this has
something to do with my policies but
okay let's move right right ran to Texas
from California I mean yeah Elon Musk is
now in Texas I mean there there are some
breadcrumbs being left by some really
smart people
they should just pick them up and see
where they lead I keep telling people I
would have paid an entry fee to get into
Florida I don't want to give that I now
and that was a Floridian I'm okay with
that idea but you know it's all right
um so I want to talk about the protect
kids act because you are are leading on
this from a legislative standpoint
related to all of the gender nonsense
but before before we do that let's do
one other social justice thing according
to my notes Here uh you are black is
that my mother and my father have
confirmed the fact I am black
okay well but wait a minute Senator uh
according to mainstream media you can't
be black and Republican I have tried to
figure that out I looked at the polling
information and the polling suggested
there's 82 percent chance that I'm black
but the chances are 100 here's what's
happening and
this is really simple anytime an
African-American who happens to be
conservative starts making Common Sense
on TV the left must and nullify the very
existence of someone they wished was a
unicorn but I am not I am real I am not
a fairy tale I am actual really here in
front of you the truth is that the most
dangerous sight they've ever seen is
someone who actually fights for the very
people they say they represent and
produces results like opportunity zones
when you think about bringing bringing
poverty to the history of America
2019 think about the fact it is the year
that the private sector invested 29
billion dollars through opportunity
zones in those marginalized communities
leading to an eight percent increase in
wages a 20 increase in property values
which closes the it shrinks the gap
between the Haves and the have-nots and
oh by the way it led to the lowest level
ever recorded for poverty that scares
the blue Dickens out of the blue the
left it's a strange thing but it works
we have the proof is in the pudding
black conservatives that stand up for
folks living in marginalized communities
represent something that MSNBC and
sometimes CNN they just can't stomach it
but here we are they can't you know I
don't know if you know this but I
campaigned with alongside Larry Elder
when during the California recall and I
would open for him at some events and
you know I'd read the headlines and
they'd say you know all the supporters
are white supremacists and he's the
black face of white supremacy and I'm
out there in front of thousands of
people waving American flags cheering
him on and they're calling them the
white supremacists like man
here's the funny thing is here's a guy
who ran for congress in 2010 against the
sun Strom Thurmond in the birthplace of
the Civil War Charleston and because of
the evolution of the Southern heart I
sit now as a United States senator for
the great state of South Carolina if we
were talking about racist not supporting
candidates of color
I wouldn't be here nor would a
successful Wesley hunt who won his his
uh Primary in Texas by the way primaries
are typically Republican primaries are
more white than the overall population
so if you want to test the theory of
race and politics go to places like
Texas or or Charleston South Carolina or
John James in Michigan and you start
noticing there's a trend that people
actually judge you based on the content
of your character not the color of your
skin ask Myra Flores or young Kim or
Michelle Steele and you'll get the same
conclusion that Americans are far more
interested
in with on the inside than we are at the
outside but Democrats the tribal nature
of identity politics requires them to
start on the outside
and use these artif the these these
these characteristics to come to an
artificial conclusion assistant with the
very theory of progress we are the land
of opportunity we are the place where
hope breathes
Eternal do you think it's possible that
Republicans or conservatives whatever
you want to call right-leaning people
was it a was it bad messaging on that
side or was the messaging of the left
just so effective to create these untrue
uh memes that you're describing because
it's not I can tell you as someone that
was a left in my whole life came across
the aisle now and it's like I meet the
most decent loving open actually more
open-minded even than the purported
open-minded people I mean that's well
one of the things I found to be quite
interesting is the definition of any
words used in in politics today like the
inflation reduction act actually
increases inflation or the fact that you
hear people talking about the Republican
Party being a group of racists or
deplorables and the truth is when the
guy from the black lives matter a leader
showed up at the Trump rally they gave
him the stage I I mean yeah and so they
applauded him for the things that they
agreed upon and they didn't boo them
they treated him with respect and
deference on the areas of disagreement
he was stunned and obviously in my
office shook us
which would you say Tim's got internal
phrase for I can't believe that happened
so literally what we find happening all
across the country is people of good
intent they welcome debate they actually
welcome this agreement what they don't
welcome is indoctrination what they
don't welcome is you telling me that
because of the color of my skin I'm an
oppressor or you frankly telling me
because of color of my skin I'm a victim
both are offensive but people of good
intent
they don't judge you based on these
superficial things they judge you based
on how the heart responds to the crisis
of the moment all right so speaking of
the crisis of the moment let's talk
about your protect kids act I've done a
ton here on on the gender stuff
obviously all the woke stuff first off
how did this even get to your desk is
there an issue a real issue with this in
South Carolina are you just kind of
modeling this off what DeSantis is doing
down here or how did it I celebrate all
the governors around the country who
take very seriously the importance
relationship between a parent and their
teachers and Governor DeSantis has led
on this and we should give him a lot of
credit for doing so what I've seen
across the country I've I've been
focused on school choice and empowering
parents for the last nine years I I love
the model that uh Jeb Bush had and Rick
Scott had and Ron desantises in in
Florida but the truth is that Governors
throughout the country including Kim
Reynolds uh in Iowa they're all all
focusing on school choice and one of the
reasons why is I had this panel and I
had parents from around the country one
from Virginia come down to Charleston
South Carolina and she says to me I
needed basically a foia a Freedom of
Information Act request just to get a
copy of my kids curriculum I can't get
into this school
and then you hear these parents in Iowa
and in Virginia who are concerned about
their kids being indoctrinated from a
gender perspective
I decided that the problems are not just
in one state they seem to be in many
states so one of the things that makes
common sense to me is the parent is the
person who should be in the biggest most
powerful position possible in making
decisions for their kids
Big labor unions and bureaucrats are in
the way of those parents making the
decisions and then working with their
teachers to carry that out I want that
to be Nationwide not in one or two
states where the governors are taking
that issue seriously every single state
when you're talking about a 12 year old
the parents should be engaged in the
decisions of their kids
that's just common sense in my house or
where I grew up I wanted to be common
sense all across the country when you
talk to the Democrats in South Carolina
and you bring this up and you talk about
transparency and okay the power back to
the parent do any of them get it I mean
again I guess it sort of gets back to
that other question we talked about but
to me something about the one with kids
maybe is a wake up sort of like what we
saw happen in Virginia with young and
winning uh when it didn't look like he
was going to win just a couple weeks
before the election absolutely the
parents do I think parents Democrat
parents get this issue as well as
Republican parents this is an issue that
actually unites parents across the board
in South Carolina they were stunned by
the developments across the country as
it relates to your ability to have a
gender identity group and to have
teachers feeling like they're forced to
provide instruction that is just
antithetical to what's in the best
interest of a child to exclude the
parent from any conversation around
those very important topics and so this
legislation would pull money away from
schools who refuse to comply with with
the law by the way of the land already
is
miners don't make decisions in a vacuum
it requires a parental supervision to
make those decisions I have to reinforce
that by pulling the money away so that
we can make them pay attention to what
the law of the land already is I always
think it's funny because I remember when
I was a kid if you if they took us to
the zoo or something at school or we
went down to DC you'd have to have a
parental slip but somehow
but now you can literally talk to a kid
about gender identity privately and hold
it for six months it's nuts Senator I
should have asked you but I should have
just Googled before I started how old
are you if you don't mind me asking
because I think we're roughly around
yeah today's my birthday I am 57. you're
today's your birthday yes sir I said
what can I do to celebrate my birthday
and the only thing I could think of Dave
wow half my people call you and beg you
to have me on today this is pretty sweet
man this is pretty sweet all right so
you're 57 57 right that's right 0.47 I'm
46. so so we're close enough you're sort
of on the I guess that would be like the
high end of Gen X I'm kind of right in
the middle of it but do you think the
reason I ask though is because as I'm
listening to you and uh and as I've you
know heard many of your speeches before
uh it seems like the message that you've
got and you're literally your age that
you are not in your late 70s 80s where
we're being governed by all of these
people that it seems like our generation
was supposed to take the reins and
somehow we missed it did something
happen there that skipped us over in a
weird way you know that's great that's a
really great question I am one of the
older generation experts that's true I
will say this that I don't know what
quite happened by the way I'm not sure
if we were too many were asleep at the
wheel and just missed that opportunity I
think we should be fully engaged in
shaping this country I think we have
enough experience enough education
enough Nicks and bruises to look back
and help those who are coming and to
look forward and to know what we should
take from our parents and what we left
on the sidelines I think we are in the
perfect age range to help recalibrate
this country for its best output yet
what do you make of the the general
thing that's happening across the
country which is that the states really
do seem to be going in very different
directions I mean I feel like I live in
a different country honestly I don't
mean that to be California to Florida
you move from almost a different country
it seems like I mean literally you know
3 000 miles but truly it feels like a
different country obviously if you live
in South Carolina that's going to feel
very different than living in New York
covet exacerbate a lot of that are you
generally okay with that concept well
listen I think we've had uh we've had
very unique and interesting times in in
American history where the states felt a
tension that at some times was not
healthy and that we overcame that I I do
think we're in another one of those
moments where we're seeing the states
divide amongst themselves naturally I
mean the good news is when you can work
and live where you want to you move from
California
to Florida you know or you should have
stopped by the way in South Carolina and
called it home we say those folks who
moved from like New Jersey to Cal to
Florida and then they come back to South
Carolina that's what typically happens
over time we call those folks halfbacks
as they went all the way down they went
all the way down they came halfway back
so Nikki Haley did a number on me too it
was on the list it was on the list
honestly I have I have family in Florida
and that really was like the they could
move up to South Carolina too no problem
we have room for
for your family as well we like red
voting cards I have a newly registered
Republican for the first time in my life
I had 46 years I love it so all right so
let's do a little bit of uh projecting
going forward here obviously these
midterms are coming you know most
conventional thinking is there's going
to be some kind of Red Wave the
incumbent party never does that well in
the midterms uh what do you think is
going to happen what do you want to
happen
well if I had my brothers we would win
the Senate with about two or three seats
to spare uh we would have the house with
about when I came into the house in 2010
I think we had 63 new seats in the house
uh that was a banner year without any
question if I had it my way we'd have
that kind of a red tsunami what I think
is going to happen I think we will
control the house at the end of this
election and there is a decent chance
that we can control the Senate as well
we need to execute on the field the the
game is coming down to the last two
minutes the score is going to be close
to tie tied and I want to make sure that
when you give the ball as a quarterback
and you turn and you give your ball to
your running back I'm I'm hoping that
Herschel will be jumping over the the
the the goal line in the air with the
ball secured no fumbles and wins back
Georgia and I'm very confident that Ted
Bud will will do a four and out and
score on his two two-minute drills out
there and I'm hoping that Dr Oz will be
the coach on the sideline and drawing up
the play and and will execute as he was
the Harvard quarterback so maybe he'll
scramble to the left and and hit the
receiver for a three-yard score and and
then JD Vance I know he's a good author
so I'm not going to play football but he
can kick the extra point heck fire and
win that race I got to tell you I'm more
of a basketball guy but the references
are all working I'm I'm following good
good I'm about done because I started
with Herschel I know nothing about
basketball but maybe we can just get JD
Vance in the dunk of all uh apps or
someone else spikes it I'm sure you
don't Spike the basketball
uh all right so but okay so if that
happens let's say you get some something
close to what you want even if it's even
if it's not that that you know three
Senators over Etc but you get some of
that exactly what do you think changes
here what do you think honestly changes
well the first thing that should change
if we control both houses is that we
start oversight we an oversight
objective to rein In This Very
unwieldly group of Democrats running
this country in the abiding
Administration they need oversight like
a three-year-old needs a parent to say
don't do this I mean literally we need
to bring the oversight hammer down
number two we have to be the party of
parents the one thing that is Manifest
today throughout this country is that
school choice and parental involvement
is now more important than it's ever
been before I think it is 67 percent of
Democrats 68 percent of The Independents
70 percent of African-Americans 74 of
Hispanics 80 of dual income Working
Families all support some form of school
choice after looking at the devastating
learning loss and the precipitous drop
in scores
we have to lead for parents that's the
second thing we should do and the third
thing we have to do uh in my opinion is
to con control our Southern border and
build a physical impediment it is a
national security risk it is a fentanyl
and Drug risk and it is two and a half
million illegal Crossing in the illegal
immigration risk and finally what is
obvious to all of us
if you just turn the spending off I
believe inflation comes down in a real
and manifest way if you start talking
about tax policy that makes sense and
and predictability in the regulatory
State people with certainty and
predictability they go back to creating
jobs they go back to making sure that
they're making long-term Investments
that helps to Spur the economic engines
in a way that attracts jobs back to
America and high-tech manufacturing and
the stem future becomes ours I know that
no Senator wants to be asked this much
less on their birthday but uh I mean the
national Ambitions will like it's it
seems like you fit in there man I mean
it just seems like the message the tone
as I said the age like it seems it seems
right to me
you know uh Dave I'll tell you my
national ambition is to travel this
country for the next seven weeks and my
home state in order to win the
majorities in the house and the Senate I
am a guy that I figured out one thing
several years ago applying for jobs is
the worst way to get a job the best way
to get a job is to do that job like no
one's ever done it before and that's one
of the reasons why in the last three
weeks or so I've been to Florence and
Myrtle Beach and Columbia and Charleston
and Anderson South Carolina as well as
Rock Hill and I'll be in Greenville and
Spartanburg and Columbia again in the
next couple weeks but I'm also in Iowa
Nebraska
Wisconsin Michigan Tennessee Florida
Georgia and North Carolina in the last
just few weeks and I'll do more of the
same in the next few weeks because I
believe that the most important
thing I can do with my time and my good
health is to invest it in the future of
America because one day there will be
kids like yours running this country and
we need to make sure they start off
looking at the city on the hill that
doesn't happen on accident I think for
the last few years we thought is that is
that the sort of scariest part of what's
going on that we seemingly have given up
just what that flag right behind you
represents just almost like that like we
just don't I know we do and the people
watching this but so much of the ethos
of America seems to have given up on
that dream and that aspirational message
you know there's there's something about
and I don't mean this to be negative and
I don't mean this to be insulting I just
mean it to be real this concept of being
a global citizen where everything is all
merged together is really unhealthy for
the United States of America the thing
that has always been a part of American
exceptionalism is not standing apart
only it's standing above it's leading
the world not being a part of it I want
to help other countries succeed beyond
their wildest imagination but that
starts by having America succeeding
beyond our wildest imagination we are
the standard when the standard becomes
average the world becomes subpar Senator
I'm gonna let you go because it's your
birthday and I said a half hour and
we're right there what do you do on your
57th birthday besides hanging out with
Dave Rubin I mean what's going on
tonight I assume I assume you're getting
out of the office in a minute you you
know I am I'm going to leave the office
I'm actually going to go for a little
bit of a run and then I'm gonna have
dinner and contemplate of the future I
have a I I love I love just doing goal
setting I did it before I became a
member of Congress it's one of the
things I do on my birthday I love just
thinking about the next 12 months and
how to make my 50s fabulous and a part
of that I will decide that the next 12
months tonight Senator I hope your
predictions are right and I'm glad we
finally got to do this I hope we can do
it in person sometime happy birthday to
you
thank you Dave God bless you and
congratulations on on being a brand
brand new father maybe again but five
years I'm going to bed right now first
one there you go God bless you take care
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell